all this talk a lot of times just you
know people trying to sound tough on the
internet look at what all these
patriotic people did in the 1700s this
is the same thing even if only two of
those out of the 100 are serious that
leads to violence there is that that
jokester adam kinzinger he is one of the
court jester conservatives he's a he's a
republican he's an elected official as a
republican but he's really
just a prop of the liberal regime his
entire point is to the entire purpose of
his political career is to
make a show of being a republican to
appear as though there is opposition
within the dominant political order but
actually whenever it matters he all he
ever does is give support to the broader
liberal establishment so kenzinger goes
on cnn of course and he's talking to
anderson cooper of course and he's
defending the dhs view that conservative
republicans are terrorists when you look
at online rhetoric and you look at
chatter that's happening and you look at
you know maybe a hundred people post
insane comments like bring out the
gallows even if only two of those out of
the 100 are serious that leads to
violence i i think what the biggest
concern is is all this talk a lot of
times just you know people trying to
sound tough on the internet but that
ends up kind of feeding itself and
particularly when people start
brainwashing folks with the election was
stolen look at what all these patriotic
people did in the 1700s this is the same
thing the masked mandate is basically
the equivalent of not allowing you to
practice your religion you know which is
1776 taxation without representation
ultimately that does grow into action
and it's a real concern so but before we
get to his broader stupid point i do
want to focus in on his on his minor
stupid points he's he's suggesting that
somehow the american revolution was
based on people not being able to
practice their religion which that he's
getting his history confused here that
was but then he corrects himself because
then he
i think he realizes that way that
actually wasn't part of it so he says
you know they're they're comparing
having to muzzle yourself at infinitum
you know at the whims of some random
technocrat they're comparing that with
no taxation without representation as
though that's just as bad and i think
look maybe i'm giving him too much
credit
but i think he's realizing as he's
saying this oh wait a minute
having to muzzle yourself
indefinitely not through the processes
of the constitutional order and the
elected government but because some
random bureaucrat just orders you to
that actually
is a bit more egregious than a tax hike
isn't it
to me it is i don't
when i think of you know i'm trying to
put myself in the mindset of 1776 and i
don't have representation in parliament
exactly but you know i'm having my taxes
raised a little bit to pay for a war
that was fought on my shores and
and i compare that to
having to
muzzle myself forever not being able to
push back against that if i even try to
voice my political opposition to that
i'll be labeled a terrorist by the
dominant regime also by agencies that
are unelected and i have no recourse
against that actually does seem worse
that actually that actually does raise
some questions about the political order
and so kenzinger is trying to work his
way
through all of this
but
kinzinger's
broader point is that if you question
any of this you're you're a terrorist
this can lead to really large-scale
terrible
stuff glad you liked that clip if you
want to catch the whole episode it's
called forget the taliban anti-massacres
are the real terrorists you can get it
here on youtube but really i would
encourage you to get it on apple
podcasts spotify google play stitcher
wherever you get your audio podcasts
really helps us circumvent some of the
shenanigans at big tech go over there
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you